hello and talk yeah all right again what
can you do every single session I have
to face this opening and then we try
that line again and now I can also take
looks funny anyway I mean he really
keeps insisting on this opening very
very very hard and you what do you do
here 95 sacrificing only three this was
probably too crazy then maybe I can
endure them a little bit with night
before and at five so move actually look
why not at five okay so night before
it's not he kept really okay you can
also just try to attack him a little bit
here let's see what happens then Bishop
takes h3s might be awesome not totally
sure about it now it is definitely on
yeah I can still take on age three it is
an idea at least probably not
objectively working I can go to f4 here
that's a simple solution light before
this Quintus III maybe so i go here he
always has the screen see three
intermediate mate threat yeah now
stacking them is probably not justified
please me this one prepare it just to be
ready to have will be 66 after the
sacrifice he will probably move the
night well maybe not sure I mean I don't
have to play for Bishop h3 it's not my
is not the only idea what to do
let's let's try to open this up I've got
the dishes Pam this is actually the
reason why I don't think that this
opening can be any good what gives up
the bishop Power Move 6444 really no
compensation I don't see they don't see
it at least I mean it looks a little bit
like an absolutely bad good normally
wouldn't as exchange okay I can take
aforehand almost possible okay well I
don't have to how does he cover you for
he anyway maybe he plays e5 takes rook
e1 from some tactics like that maybe
that could that could work actually
yeah the depth it was possible but I
have fished should be 65 so it's not
some things to become to be worried
about much maybe I should have gone to
e7 actually and at least have the option
of of playing Bishop g5 yeah you know no
I gotta move it again I'd ever came it's
not not too critical what i do first air
me I will play gt5 ambition t5a Bishop
g5 first of cook em yeah and I'm being
too relaxed um i'm being too relaxed it
was more precise to play Bishop c5 first
and prevent this all together
yeah I should have prevented it that
would have been a lot easier to play
them however it's still good yeah i'm
preparing the 55 p.m. anyway and now
yeah this law h5 this is going to be
weak yeah okay let's crack the pawn okay
it's still good chef is with with the
trade so what to do maybe c5 and bishop
[Music]
you should see facts going to play
deform it is probably correct make the
for more difficult
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it wasn't precise the game should
have been over already with a mating
attack but I have to play an ending if
not really what should have happened and
it's a pretty good ending but it was so
bad that an ending shouldn't have
happened okay
[Music]
okay check why was it on time now I was
not really satisfied that was so bad for
why that there shouldn't never be an
ending really okay so let's have a look
roughly from him yeah 93 is Wow yeah I
mean his reckoning is long I agonal he
and tremendously it's funny that the
engine says I can take what i can take
because the tanks you cannot pin me ask
you but it could have taken it I thing
is that this is actually also fantastic
because I get here and I can guarantee
you this is stocked fishing on 20 oh you
cannot really see that all that well why
is that
I have to trust the syllabus now it's
better sorry I didn't did I wasn't aware
of that if you give it more time it
would probably give a higher email this
is just some very very bad here here and
now I should be a bit more precise and
make sure that I don't have to play an
ending I mean this yeah but it is it is
fantastic so yeah why not if this ending
is a lot better for black at the end he
is sitting there with the weaknesses
that's very difficult or two defenders
stuff move the entrance fee value is if
it isn't in that high why isn't that
winning the pole and three what is the
problem here and this is just supposed
to be 0.4 why I just play be 65 and or
is that such an unlucky pinning
situation that I'm not winning this may
be so easy it isn't really I mean that
was definitely easier to play now okay
that that was entirely uncritical yeah
probably you can be more precise like
not take immediately I hope the aid for
this yes okay we can play that more
precisely but okay yeah also spin
suspected that it will be
on time okay thanks for watching